[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we got some sad news i'm going to be
taking a a step back from being on uh
king and the sting
and
[Music]
i just want to thank you guys for just
being a part of my life and and letting
this show be a part of your life and um
you know i'm
grateful to you brendan mann i
appreciate it
um
and yeah today was a lot of fun and the
best yeah it was the best it was today
was awesome funniest guy i know
thanks bro
i appreciate that man um
[ __ ] we've been doing what four years i
don't know has it been that long mm-hmm
man yep
yeah i uh
[Music]
she's gotta handle some [ __ ] brother you
got there's a bigger
thing for you out there you know
today is monday september 12th and
theovan has announced he is no longer a
part of the king and the sting the
announcement aired on friday with theo
saying that he still plans to pop in
from time to time but is no longer
officially a part of the show and as
always welcome back to the joke world
comedy update every single monday
bringing you all the comedy news that
you need to know from your favorite
podcast your favorite comedians people
going on each other's shows new episodes
coming out new specials airing
everything happening in the comedy world
all in one place so please consider
subscribing to joke world right now
turning on the post notifications and
downloading this episode on spotify to
support the channel there'll be some
times where i'll pop back in you know um
but
just just i just don't want to kind of
leave that in the lurch i feel like i've
left it there for a while and it's
probably made it uncomfortable as a
listener maybe and just as a people
working here too you know not to be able
to you know be sure of me so theovon
leaves the king singing the wing a lot
of people saw this coming for a while
but many were still upset about how it
went down with people on reddit saying
it was a little too casual for what most
people say is the best part of the show
theo van this person on reddit said i
can't believe how the show is ending
there should have been a farewell
episode to theo he is the king in the
sting this show is not the same without
him four years and a two minute goodbye
shaking my head r.i.p other posts were
calling at the end of the show so people
wanted to see a goodbye for theo maybe
not such a casual ending but hopefully
his pop-ins are still good for the king
and sting fans it's it's still an
exciting show and there's great people
here and um
[Music]
and
i think that that's
important you know that there's that
it's a great show still
uh for being grateful of chris and eric
and everyone yeah and for people to
enjoy man the show looks so different
than it did when it started i think a
lot of people assumed that theo
eventually would leave even andrew
schultz commented on an episode this
past weekend he thinks theo's just gonna
quit sorry brandon the bi
the podcast is up
it's just gonna be some sting brandon
oh it's been staying for a couple weeks
over there
joe rogan announced that comedy
mothership will be the name of his new
club in austin texas he's been teasing
the idea of opening up his own comedy
club ever since he moved a few years ago
but he's always been very protective and
secretive over what the name is going to
be whenever he got brought up on his
podcast he'll say i'll tell you the name
after or he'd say i'll go show you and
tell you all the details after it's just
recently that he actually started to say
the name of the club when he's talking
about it on the podcast like he said it
to samurail he said to christina p the
comedy mothership i don't really love
the name but it is very on brand for joe
rogan i i would expect nothing less from
him and he also used to refer to the
comedy store in la as the mothership so
this makes sense he's a huge supporter
of the comedy store and the tradition
there and he probably wants to pay some
sort of tribute this is the tiny little
room
that a lot of times we use
to write [ __ ] from
that's the stage that's the mic stand
that's where it all goes down
that sound the background is the vacuum
cleaner because this [ __ ] ain't all just
glamorous
you gotta clean up
every time he's mentioned the club on
his podcast he says he wants it to be a
hub for comedians all across the country
to pop in whenever they want whether
they're on the road or they're local to
austin to work out jokes and to feel
safe and creative all the phones from
the audience members are going to be
locked in the magnetic bags during the
show so nothing will be filmed no
content will be leaked and rogan has
always said that he has no intentions to
make a profit off of this club he only
wants to break even which is just
another example of why joe rogan is the
[ __ ] man we have a new podcast from
aria shafir called two comics and two
cigars the description on the
announcement video is welcome to the new
two comics two cigars youtube channel
stand up comedians ari shafir and bobby
kelly love a good cigar and want you to
join them their first episode will
feature ari and bobby and the cigar of
their choice after that it will always
be two comics and two cigars
two two two comics
two cigars two comics two cigar two
two comics two cigars that's the that's
a good title holy [ __ ]
that's it well that's it two comics two
cigars a little bitter would be about
the cigar yeah and the rest is just
conversation yeah while we're smoking
said cigar one hour but two comments and
two cigars
here we are you can have any two comics
it doesn't have to be us doesn't have to
be us it can be it can be two comedians
half the time could be you and i
together the other half of time could be
either me and somebody else you and
somebody else or two other people it's
an hour long it's however long it takes
you to smoke the cigar i love it
one comic is better than the other they
both think it's them and one comment
the one comic that's better than the
other is not that in shape but the other
one is
i like the idea of a podcast that isn't
even the same host every time like as
long as it's two comedians and they're
smoking cigars it could be any two
people which is pretty funny that's a
new idea creative idea i'm definitely
going to be keeping tabs on two comics
and two cigars
guest spots from last week ari shafir
was on your mom's house two bears one
cave was tom and bert burt and tom tiger
belly was bobby lee by himself with
shake well
are you garbage talk to sam morell i was
flying from texas to burlington vermont
not good routing obviously for a giver
uh you know weekend in vermont and it's
like that it's you know when you're on
the runway and you're like i'm not gonna
make the connection i'm connecting in
your home philly i'm you know i'm like a
two-hour delay the flight attendant's
like i think you're gonna make it i
don't think i'm gonna make it but she's
really building me up she's like i think
they're gonna hold the plane i was like
they don't they don't hold planes that's
not a thing they do for one dude anyway
then i got morel coming up
throw the brakes on dude i get i land
and she just goes run i think you can
make it so i'm running and it's like we
land in b2 and i'm like please be close
[ __ ] f 32.
it kills me so i'm sprinting they close
the door right as i'm getting i'm like
please don't close it she goes sorry
closes it what the [ __ ] and she goes i
can't open it it's closed i'm like but
you [ __ ] you closed
so then i had to go from uh there's a
day it came out and i go what the [ __ ]
as i'm doing oh what the [ __ ] i'm
yelling phones are coming up and i'm
like i'm gonna go viral the day my
special comes out for not my
i'm going what the [ __ ] why would you do
that and uh i know i'm gonna miss the
gig that night so i'm just furious
she goes i can get you on a flight to
chicago so i'm going back to chicago to
burlington so that's and i was like what
do i do and she goes uh you got the
board in seven like it's bored now you
got seven minutes to get there i said
where is it i [ __ ] you not b4
[Laughter]
sam was also on the joe rogan experience
and they had a great conversation about
comedy it was funny it was insightful
and it was just pleasant all together i
definitely recommend samurail's jre
episode from last week paulie shore was
on whiskey ginger flagrant told stories
from going to burning man last week all
the boys come to burning man which is
the most magical place on earth is
literally my favorite place in existence
i think it's the most creative
inspirational kindest most generous i'm
the best version of myself there and i
think you find the most uh impressive
and incredible version of humanity there
that being said there is a cost
there is a cost we didn't do a tuesday
episode so apologies for that oh yeah
yeah yeah we didn't do a tuesday episode
that's part of the cost you've always
got to pay too you guys had to pay in
that regard uh so we have a lot of funny
stories that i'm sure we'll get in i
don't know exactly where to start from
this kill tony tonight is the entire
protector parks crew it starts off with
just mark norman shane gillis and ari
shafir and then joe rogan joins him
about an hour in he says it's the most
[ __ ] up he's ever been during a
podcast i listen to audio it's very
funny so i'm excited for the video
tonight and then also the joke world
podcast last week we interviewed john
jacobs a very funny comedian that was a
very enjoyable episode so if you like
these comedy news updates please
consider checking out our podcast it
will be linked in this top banner right
now
new comedy specials from last week you
still have samurail same time tomorrow
out on netflix and brian callan man
tiers on youtube those are both good
watches if you're looking for some
specials to get into this has been
another episode of the joke world comedy
update thank you so much for watching
please consider subscribing liking this
episode download it on spotify you know
follow us on instagram we'll send you
some free stickers just keep supporting
the brand if you love comedy thank you
so much for everyone who subscribed so
far i'll see you next monday
[Music]
you